National Geographic Kids presents the
ultimate Dino pedia Carnotaurus don't
mistake this Dino for a t-rex both
species hail from the theropod group
fast ferocious meat-eaters that were
closely related to birds but the horned
bowl-like Carnotaurus had arms even
smaller than the t-rex Styracosaurus
this creatures head was wildly colorful
it used its big beak to grab plants in
the forest scientists think the
Styracosaurus may have been able to run
up to 16 miles per hour faster than an
elephant
spinosaurus named for its enormous spine
which rose like a sail from its back
reaching up to seven feet high its jaws
were like those of a crocodile with
nostrils on top
perfect for breathing while partly
submerged underwater
you